الملحد والعملاء يأخذون النظام
من أغرب الأشياء التي مررت بها على الإطلاق
وواحد من أكثر الأحداث عاطفية
أنا أخبرك الآن يا أخي
أنا آخذ طلبًا أحضره
أقول مرحبا يا هاني
ذكر سلمى سلامون عليكوم معلم
أنا أطلب شيئا
أنا أعطي الأمر للرجل Selamun Aleyküm
أقول إنه لم يتلق تحية قلت هيا
أعتقد أنه كان مشتتًا ، مرحبًا
يقول مرحبًا مرة أخرى ، أخذت الثانية
قال أنني أخذته إلى الثالث
لم أستطع الوقوف فقلت أستاذي قلت مرحبًا
نحن نحمد الله ، لماذا نعطي
قال شيئا مثل أخي قلت مسلم
قال إنني لست ، إنها نار ، حسناً؟
محمد محمد أم خالتي
أخي ، أنا أيضًا ، بالطبع ، إيمان الجميع محترم
علينا أن نسمع أنني أتيت إلى المحل ولكن
القليل من الغطرسة هنا مطعمي أيضًا
قلت للمالك ، انظر إلى السلطة غدًا
قلت انه ملحد الاسم محمد او شيء من هذا القبيل
قال محمد: بلاه بلاه لماذا تقول ذلك
ربما بلاه بلاه بلاه لكن مطعمك
لا اذكر اسم صاحب المطعم
لأن المالك يغضب
ذهبت إلى الكمبيوتر وسجلت ملاحظة للعميل
لاحظ اسمك ورقم هاتفك كل شيء
من الواضح أنني اشتريتها إذا طلبت مرة أخرى
ستفعل شيئًا يا أخي لقد مر يومان
أمر الرجل مرة أخرى
قال الرئيس ، سآخذ واحدة ، توقف
وضع الكتاب فيه قال هذا الكتاب قل لي
إعطائها للعميل الذي أرسله الرئيس سلبه
قلت ، سيدي ، مثل هذا ، هذا الكتاب
ترسل صاحبنا إلى المطعم
أخذته يا أخي ، هكذا يتم فحص الكتب
بدأت تتكاثف حسنا؟
هذا هو الرجل الذي يدافع عن الإسلام.
إرسال كتب للآخر يدافع عن الإلحاد
يتم تشغيل الكتب وهي الآن رقيقة جدًا
بدأنا في تكثيف الكتب
أنا مؤسسة جميلة
يا صاح ، لقد مرت 3 أشهر ، لقد كنت دائمًا هكذا
أحضرت كتابًا أخذته
ننظر بين بعضنا البعض على الهاتف
لم يتحدثوا بهذه الطريقة من WhatsApp
لم يتصلوا ويتحدثوا هكذا قط
لقد أخذت الكتاب للتو مثل هذه الرسالة
لقد أخذته بين شهرين وإخوانه 3 أشهر
بعد 3 أشهر خرج هذا الرجل
جاء إلى المطعم بين المطعم 3-4
يوجد على بعد كيلومتر مطعم مان
وجدني قال مرحبا قال مرحبا
أنا آسف لأنه رآني Selamunaleyküm
قال
قلت مرحبا أخي
اين كان المالك؟
كأنه رأى صاحب المطعم
رجل كأنه أحبري منذ 40 سنة.
مرحبا اخي قال ذلك بالطبع
لذلك فهو شعور مختلف
قال للمطعم هل يمكننا التحدث على انفراد
مرروا المالك إلى الخلف يا أخي من الغرفة.
شخص ما يبكي قادم من الغرفة الخلفية
خلف المحل
قلت شيئا لبعضنا البعض
إنهم يفعلون ذلك يا أخي ، إنه رجل يا محمد
رجل تحول إلى مسلم كلمة ط
لمشاركة من كان مسلمًا من قبل
جاء وعانقني ، مطعمنا
مالك يبكي أنا أبكي بشكل متوقع
لأنه شعور مختلف
الأكثر اختلافًا والأجمل التي مررت بها عندما جفت
كان أحد الأحداث
لذلك أنا لا أعرف
لذا فهو شيء مختلف
نحن السعاة دائما نقول فقط
نحن لا نحمل عبوات ، كما تعلمون ، جنوط كهذه
نحن نحمل أو شيء من هذا ، نقول ، حقًا
احيانا مشاعرك احيانا مشاعرك
مشاعرك
شيء مختلف يا أخي ، فقط عن طريق البريد
تأكد من أنها تحمل عبوة على المحرك
لا تنظر
كنت أغرب شيء مررت به على الإطلاق